Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Hugo Drochon. He's associate
professor in political theory at the University of Nottingham,
and today we're going to talk about his latest
book Elites and Democracy. So Dr. Rochon, welcome to
the show. It's a pleasure to
everyone. It's a pleasure for me to be on
it, Ricardo. I'm looking forward to the discussion.
Yeah, likewise. So I mean, I think that probably
we should start with a few definitions here because
if I understood it correctly, when it comes to
democracy, for example, the way that you explore it
and perhaps define it in your book is different
from the way that most people, I would say,
understand it. So could you explain that?
OK, right, right to the heart of the matter,
Ricardo. OK, well done. It's true, yes, when people
talk about democracy, what do they have in mind?
They have, you know, in kind of definitional terms,
you talk about sovereignty of the people, or majority
rule, and if you want to go a bit
further with that, I don't know how, for instance,
um, and uh familiar some of your listeners might
be, or viewers might be with, you know, have
this Joseph Schumpeter, famously led, you know, the, the
conventional view of democracy is that people come together,
they, they develop a kind of a general will,
and then they elect representatives to then execute that
general will. Obviously, he didn't want to turn that
around to something else. And the position I want
to defend it is not dissimilar to that, or
it has a variation on it, because the book
asks, OK, there's this tradition. Um, IN political theory
and in democratic theory, um, uh, more generally, where
we say, actually, even though there are, even though
we are live in a, in a modern democracy,
elites still rule. So if elites still rule, then
that seems to problematize this idea that democracy might
be sovereignty of the people, right? Because it's not
the people are sovereign, it seems to be that
the elites hold the power, or even majority rule,
because the idea here is that minorities rule. So
what can democracy mean in that setting? And so
in the book, I try to develop a term
that I've coined, if you want, and I'm proposing
for general discussion, which is called dynamic democracy. And
there's a few elements there, I think, to unpack
slightly. The, the first is to say, OK, If
we think that there are always elites, even in
modern democracies, then the way to think about politics
more generally is to say that politics is the
continual, the perpetual struggle of, um, rising elites against
established elites, that there's this perpetual kind of churn.
There's established elites who get challenged by rising elites,
and in that moment of challenge is where you
make, you may get political change. That's a broader,
um, kind of conception of democracy. Then the dynamic,
and so that's what makes it dynamic, because there's
a perpetual kind of change. That's the dynamic aspect
to it. The democratic aspect then of this kind
of combos to say, OK, but in the moment
of challenge, what type of challenge is it? Is
it something that might further democracy or actually retract
democracy if you want? And it's true that this
conception wants to say, instead of having a kind
of dichotomy where either you have a democratic regime,
or you have an authoritarian or oligarchic regime, whatever
you might be. You think about these as more
on a continuum toward, towards more democracy or towards
more oligarchy. And so the question then the democracy
is, the democracy understood here in relatively conventional terms
as, as aiming towards democracy. So more political equality,
so more participation, social or economic, um, equality too.
And actually, that's one of the distinctions perhaps already
to the Schumpeter, which we may go back to,
which is quite a limited perception of, of democracy
or politics more, more broadly, but mine is, uh,
I think a bit more expansive. So, so there's
this dynamism, which is perpetual challenge, and the democratic
aspect is, does that challenge move towards democracy understood
as greater equality in the political, economic, or social
sphere, or inversely, because you never know, right? Does
it go in the other direction, and it takes,
it moves away from political equality. And so that's
the idea is to offer a framework then within
which we can then analyze specific historical or even
contemporary moments. So, because I do take the, the
foundation for a lot of this theory is quite
historical, um, which means that you, you can't just
develop an abstract theory, um, of democracy, say, this
is democracy, yes or no. The point is to
say, here's a framework, and then we can use
that framework to analyze either historical moments or even
our own, um, moment itself and say, OK, well,
this looks to be a challenge that might go
in the direction of democracy, um, or not. And
obviously, though, that latter part is a, is, um,
It's a kind of a question of application or
of judgment. Um, THE, the, the, the theory as
such doesn't tell you what's going to happen. It
tells you, it gives you the analysis when in
which, you know, what happens. So that's what I've
tried to develop with this idea of dynamic democracy,
but based on the fact, and people may not
agree with this, based on what I think to
be a, a kind of the fact of oligarchy,
if you accept it's a fact of oligarchy, then
you need to rethink democracy, and here's my proposal
for how we might do so.
So before I ask you more about the interplay
that you explore in your book between elites on
the one hand and democracy on the other hand,
Who are the elites? I mean, what do you
mean by that term? Because I mean when we
think or talk about elites, depending on who's talking
about it, I mean, probably philosophers, political theorists, political
scientists who would have a more sophisticated, let's say,
understanding of elites, but I mean regular. People might
just think that oh elites are whoever rules us.
It can be whoever dominates the economy. It can
be whoever dominates politics, whoever dominates culture, basically who
has the most influence over people's lives in general,
right? So, but what is your take on that?
Yeah, and actually, maybe the people are right, you
know, that's, that's actually that normally the, the, the,
the, the death fish that's given. So what I
can say, if you go specifically to um Pareto,
Wilfredo Pareto, who maybe your listeners or viewers will
know Pareto mainly in the economic sphere. They might
have heard of economic efficiency or Pareto, sorry, Pareto
efficiency. Or the 80/20 rule, um, the idea that
yeah, it's the Pareto distribution, exactly,
Pareto distribution or the power law, as it's sometimes
called, the idea that Pareto came up with this
idea by studying land distribution in Italy and then
in Latin America, where he says, OK, 20% of
the population will always own 80% of the land,
and You can hear echoes obviously of that today
with the 99% of the 1%, and actually, funnily
for Pareto too, he was a keen gardener, and
he found that 20% of his pea pods produced
80% of the peas. So maybe there's a link
there between the two. But he, but Pareto, specifically
in his, in his later career after the economics,
he looked a bit more at sociology, if you
want, or democratic theory. He's the one who gives
us the term elite, as we understand it today.
Your, your definition that you gave us, is more
or less correct. Um, AND it's quite an interesting
story because it's elite with the accent, because, um,
Pareto's actually half French, his mother's French. He's teaching
in Lausanne in Switzerland at the time as part
of this Lausanne School of Economics. So he uses
the French term elite with the accent when he's
writing in French, naturally, but then when he writes
also in Italian, he keeps the French word elite,
and it's only much later that it loses its
accent. Um, I think I've looked at. Um, TODAY,
in English, at least, I, I, I don't know
what it might be in Portuguese, but in English
it's only the New Yorker that still use elite
with the accent, which I think says more about
the New Yorker than anything else. Uh, IN
Portuguese we say elite, so it's pretty close.
Was it with the accent still, or is the
accent gone? No,
we don't use the accent, we just pronounce it
elite either way,
exactly. So he's. He's really the one who gives
us the modern theory of elite, because he doesn't
want to use like the nobility or the aristocracy
which is associated with the old regime. He's like,
OK, we're in a modern democratic setting, but a
small group of people still rule, so what are
we going to call them? We're going to call
them elite. And he does this for the first
time in 1902. So the term that we use
today, elite, is actually coined like 120 years ago,
124 years ago. Um, AND he says, as you
rightly pointed out, he says, you look at all
spheres of activity, of human activity, whether they're legal
or illegal, by the way, and you, and you
judge people within that by saying, well, who are
the best? It's, it's a bit more who are
the best and who perhaps has power. So you
say, OK, well, who, who's the best chess player?
If it's Garry Kasparov, you say, OK, Garry Kasparov,
he was a grand chess master, probably give him
a 10 out of 10. Whereas me, I can't
even remember the chess. Um, RULES most of the
time, they probably give me a -1 or a
-2. And then, but you look, you look at
other, um, instances, you say, what about, you know,
courtesans, you know, um, Madame de Pompadour, you know,
she was a very powerful, very successful courtesan. Maybe
you give her a 9 or a 10. Again,
if you give me a courtesan, my charm is,
um, pretty, um, useless, so you probably give me
a -1 or 2. So that all, you could
do that in all spheres of activity. But then
Pareto makes a distinction, which you're also alluding to.
There's, there's non-political and there's political elites, right? So
there's a distinction between the two. And then what
he, what he says, there's political elites who, who,
who rule, um, but there are two types of
political elites, and I'm sure all your, your, your
viewers or listeners will remember Machiavelli, Machiavelli and the
prince. He says the ideal prince is a combination
of these two animals, the lion and the fox.
Um, THE, you need the lion to scare off
the wolves who are trying to take you down,
but you also need to be a fox to
avoid the snares or the traps that the lion.
Um, MAY fall on it. And Pareto takes that
idea and he says, OK, we're gonna say, we're
gonna apply it to this idea of elite. We
say there's two types of elites. If it's the
lions who are in power, then you'll get a
certain type of rule, a much more centralized, a
much more faith-based rule, and one much more willing
to use force. Whereas if it's the foxes are
in power, it's more decentralized, more skeptical, and less
willing to use force. So Breto says, OK, basically,
you have a circulation of elites. THROUGHOUT human history,
sometimes the lions are in power, sometimes the foxes
are in power, and obviously, it's always a question
of degree. It's always, well, the lions are kind
of a bit more power. And you also have
this idea of circulation. Again, another Machiavellian type of
image, if you remember Fortuna being a river, he
says, OK, well, sometimes there's just a small slow
tributary, and, you know, one of the lions takes
over slowly from the foxes or vice versa. But
sometimes you get a storm. And the river breaks
its banks. And so there you have more of
a revolt or revolution. So that's, that's, Pareto gives
us this theory of elites. Um, AND, and I
think as you rightly say, uh, as you say,
most people, it's kind of trickled down, that's probably
not the right word to use, but people instantly
understand it. So, he really gave us how we
understand elite today.
Mhm. Yeah, even though, let me just say, and
I'm not sure if you would agree with this
or not, because I just want to say this
because earlier, for example, I said that elites can
be elites in the political domain, in the economic
domain, in the cultural domain, for example, and probably
we could refer to other domains of life in
society, but nowadays, I mean, Not just nowadays, but
I guess that even historically, even distinguishing, for example,
strictly between economic elites and political elites is very
tricky because economics goes usually very well married with
the two politics, right?
You're absolutely right, and that's the link between the
power distribution, the 80/20 rule. And elites in itself.
And for Pareto, it's obvious that the political elites
will often then also be a form of economic
and social and social, not necessarily, but there's a
link between the two. Although there are other thinkers
who are also theorists of elite or minority rule,
Gaetana Mosca and Robert Mikelstein also in the book,
and they don't necessarily make a direct link between,
between the two. THERE'S different, there's different theories about
what is the re the link between um. The
two, and the other thing I will add, which
I think you were hinting to actually in some
ways in your question is that, um, just because
Preto is conscious of the fact that, um, you
know, uh, you, you may have certain people who
do rule, who, who have the power, but they
may not be the best. So de facto and
de jure is not the same thing. And in
fact, Pareto was very critical of some of the
elites of his time. Um, IN the 1920s, he
writes about, um, Italy, and he denounces Italy as
a form of demagogic plutocracy. That behind the facade
of democracy, the rich rule, and he, he denounced
it, so it's a kind of the, it's the
fox who kind of rule, kind of by, by,
you know, by, by, by decentralization, and they're also
kind of hiding behind something, so it's, it's not
as, it's not as obvious, um. And then obviously
his theory suggested that, well, if the Foxes are
in power, then the lions would come in to
replace them. And then you get into these controversial
questions about, well, did Pareto anticipate was the theory
anticipating Mussolini, or did he also welcome Mussolini, given
that we know in Italy afterwards. So just to
say, just to, just to clarify, I think some
of those points too.
And I mean, of course, I would imagine that
different theorists will have different understandings of What it
would mean to be for the elites or the
rulers to be the best people out there, right?
But, I mean, what does it mean or in
your understanding, what would it mean for the people
who are part of the elites to be the
best? I mean, what does that mean? Is it
for them to make the best decisions for the
majority of the population, the best decisions for society
more generally? To put it in that way, or
for them to, I mean, be the most virtuous
people out there, for them to be the ones
that are less greedy, the ones who are, who
are not the hoarders of money or economic assets
and ruin society over time, I mean, what, what
does it, what does that mean exactly? Or what
should we expect from elites?
Very good question. I think there's different answers to
that in terms of what Pareto thought and what
maybe I also say in terms of dynamic democracy.
Um, BUT, but what's true of all of these
is that this is quite contextual, right? So a
certain, um, elite is better at a certain time
than others, and actually, all of these people will
do a historical, um, analysis of different elites over
time to say, OK, sometimes there's a military elite
that dominates, sometimes it's a financial one, sometimes also
it's a kind of a more priest, priestly one,
right? Or a more kind of aristocratic one. So,
you, you could tell, sir, and then, The question,
um, for, for Pareto, given he was an economist,
he was quite concerned about economic growth and, and
these types of aspects. So that would have been
one of the criteria for him. Um, AND there
is within this, this theory, obviously, a relationship between,
between the elites and the people more, more generally,
um, because it's the rising, you know, people who,
who challenge the established elites. Um, AND for Perreto,
given that, um, he has a slightly complicated language,
but what he really means to say is that
sometimes there's different sentiments that dominate in, in the
population and the elites at large. There's a sentiment
that gives, uh, uh, that's linked to the lions,
and there's a sentiment that's linked to the foxes.
And he does say, oh, if the, if the
elites, whether they're lions or foxes, If they're, if
they're too separated, if they're too contrary to what
the people want, this will often lead to revolt.
So that's not something positive. So, there has to
be some link between the two. And in fact,
Pareto, one of his biggest worries was what he
called crystallization, that elite would become so closed and
wouldn't allow for the circulation, that what would end
up there would be a revolt and a revolution.
So he was kind of, those were the different
elements he would have used um to try to
Make sense of it. And obviously, for me, in
the dynamic democracy, hopefully you have a normative answer
to it there, which is say, OK, these types
of elites who are either there or who are
being, who are challenging, which ones are the ones
that go, that push more, the cursor towards democracy
understood as different forms of equality. So, there's a
way of answering in two forms, but it's always,
it always has to be, you can't just answer
that slightly in the abstract. It always has to
be linked to historical kind of context, because certain
elites. Like Pareto has, and, and some of the
other figures I look at, they have specific suggestion
as to which elites would be the best at
that moment in time. But that moment in time
is, you know, in 1910s, 1920s, is a very
different moment to our moment. Um, BUT we can
use those ideas, I think, to think about which
would be the best elites that we would need
for today, and they would be different, they would
be different in Portugal than it might be in
France, and it might be the UK than the
US. But here's a framework within which we can
hopefully give a sense of which ones we might
need.
Um, WHAT do political parties represent within a democracy?
I mean, what role do they play and what
do we need political parties for?
Yeah, great question, because this is why we talk
about, um, these people writing in the context of,
of modern democracy as opposed to ancient democracy, right,
the ancient Greeks. Because they, they're all arriving in
a period where there's certain developments which we would
recognize as being part of our own form of
government, namely, the spread of universal suffrage. One thing
also, the idea of representation rather than direct democracy.
But linked to this universal suffrage, which brings a
lot more people into politics than you would have
had before, you also have a rise of these
kind of modern bureaucratic political parties, mass parties, right,
that bring Um, bring the people in, into politics
and try to give them, try to give them
a bit of a political education, I suppose, in
some ways. We often think of the, the emblematic
example of this is obviously the socialist parties or
the workers' parties, whichever version of that that we
have over the course of the 20th century. It
was a way of integrating the workers into politics
in the way that they hadn't been integrated before.
So that's the specific role. Um, AND that's a
feature of that time, the rise of the centralized
bureaucratic parties. And this is why we think about
at the same time, we have another, uh, figure.
I look like Mikhaels, but he's close to Weber.
Weber, it's all about bureaucratization. That's the role traditionally
they've played. They played as this kind of intermediary
role, um, um, you know, which even Tocqueville, when
he's talking about intermediary institutions in the US, he
didn't necessarily have political parties in mind, but that's
the role that they're meant to play. And I
think some of the challenges we're probably facing today
in politics is precisely. See that this political parties,
political parties, no longer play the same role that
they used to play. They've been, there's this, um,
actually half Irish, half Scottish, I think, political theorist
called Peter Mayer, who talked about ruling the void,
that political parties have been hollowed out, that they
no longer have mass memberships like they used to.
They're much more linked to the state, so they
don't play this intermediary role. And somebody like, somebody
like Mikels or Weber. Precisely saw that the, the
role of this intermediate class was, was to mediate
between elites and the people, if you want, right?
It was a way of, and the fact that
we've lost a lot of that mediation is perhaps
is one of the explanations of why we have
more populists at the moment. I say we have
populist views because populists say that they have a
direct link to the people. There's a direct link,
right? Uh, THEY'RE the incarnation of the people. There's
no mediation there, which is what political parties, um,
used to play. So if we are worried about
the populist turn, if you want to, in, in
our politics, then revivifying or finding something that can
play the same intermediary role of political parties seem
to be very, seems to be very important.
I would like to ask you now, how do
you look at the relationship or the interplay between
populism and elitism, because I mean, please correct me
if I'm wrong, because of course I'm not the
political theorist here, but I mean the way I
look at populism, at least, I think that it
can have, there can be a positive version or
a negative version of it. The positive version is
so. We are populist in the sense that we
are trying as political representatives the best we can
to serve the interests of the vast majority of
people in society, and so we are populists in
the sense that we are going along with the
will of the people, if, if that's a good
term to use here. And then the negative version
of it would be, I mean, Feeding people with
simplistic narratives about the current political predicament to serve
the interests of the elites or of the people
who want to become elite. So I mean, what
do you think about that and then tell us
more broadly about how you look at the relationship
between populism and elitism.
Yeah, I think in some ways, you put your
finger on both elements, which I think are actually
true. So one of the ways of articulating this
is Pareto has this very simplistic kind of um
formula, if you want, for the circulation of elites,
as he puts it, he says, OK, there's a,
which is the establishment. ELITE B, which is the
rising elite that's challenging A, and then you have
C, who are the people. And so, basically, the
way this works is that B says to C,
look, A is not representing you and it's not
doing, you know, the best interest for you. So,
come over to our side, we'll overthrow A, and
we'll give you a better deal. Um, AND, you
know, actually, within Peretto's theory and with, and with
the dynamic democracy that I defend more broadly, it
may be the case that B gives the C
a better deal. But, um, and we, we can
use hopefully the dynamic democracy paradigm to try to
interpret to see whether that's correct or not, uh,
by judging which type of, you know, form of
rule or which type of policies you may pursue,
whatever it might be. But the claim is also
to say that C will never rule. C will
always remain C, the people. And so, if B
comes to power, what you will then subsequently get
is you'll get D that comes along and says,
you know, C is not representing you, or sorry,
B is not representing you. C, come over to
our side and then we'll, we'll challenge B, and
then you keep going like that. But it's in
one of those moments of challenge that something better
may happen. But again, to underline, and I think
This is what you're pointing to, and I think
sometimes has been, yeah, it's, it's not that it's
been overlooked by some of the populist literature, but
I simply wanted to put a bit more emphasis
on it, is that populists themselves, or populist leaders
are always some form of elite. They don't come
from, from nowhere, right? And I think that's sometimes
we never see. So if we take If you
take the populist literature and populism in some ways
has been for the last 10 years, the main
analytical lens that has been used to, to interpret
a lot of the political events, whether, you know,
the UK, Brexit, or in the US, um, you
know, Donald Trump, I'm sure there are examples. I'm,
I'm sorry, I'm afraid I don't know Portuguese politics
sufficiently well, but I can imagine, but you have
Chega, right? Don't you,
or yeah, yes. There's a very populist far right
party called Shige in Portugal, yes,
which I think I know what that means also,
but I perhaps won't repeat what it means online.
So you have these examples also throughout Europe or
even across the world where you have a kind
of a rise of populist, populist leaders, shall we
say, and the literature, if you think of people
like Jan Werner Muller, right, the great German political
scientist who's in Who's in Princeton who say, well,
populism has these two elements, actually, you know, one,
a rejection of the elites, um, this, this division
of politics into, you know, the pure people versus
a corrupt few that need to be rejected or
overcome. But he, the one thing he adds to
it, um, was to say that actually populism, as
opposed to more regular democratic politics is anti-pluralist. It
claims that only they are the true people, you
know, you can't have plurality or whatever it might
be. Um, BUT I'd like to think you could,
you could bring this kind of populism. So I
don't want to deny that. I think that's all
very interesting and it sheds light. But I just
wanted to put a bit more emphasis on the
fact that these populist leaders are often elites, like
Donald Trump. OK, yes, he perhaps in 2016, he
wasn't a, he wasn't a DC Washington DC political
insider, but he's surely an elite, right? He's surely
a member of the 1%. Uh, HE was a
media personality with The Apprentice. So he's an elite
type of figure who's then using, he's a kind
of a B, who's using C to overthrow A.
Um, AND A is, um, in this instance, is,
um, you know, Washington DC had all drained the
swamps. It's not just the Democrats, but it's also
the Republicans. To, right? There's a, there's a complete
shift um over. So that's maybe one way of
trying to interpret what's happened in the last 10
years, or it gives you a slightly different perspective
as a form of circulation of elites of an
elite challenging um another elite, um. And maybe another
way, final way, if we continue with, with Pareto,
maybe a way of trying to characterize that is
that previously, the, the foxes were in power, and
now the Lions have taken over, right? That, that
Trump and some of these figures are much more
line-like in, in the rule, it's much more centralized,
right? If you think about the US, the executive
has really taken over. Much more willing to use
force, much more kind of a faith-based politics. That's
very different to Barack Obama, um, if you just
want to keep it in the US, um, context.
So that's, that's what this, uh, theories, what I'm
trying to do is to shed this other light,
not to deny other things, but put a slightly
different emphasis, give us another way to think about
it, and then hopefully with dynamic democracy, give us
a way of trying to evaluate, um, evaluate it
too.
Yeah, by the way, shege means enough in English
also for my English speaker audience, I mean, which
also I guess tells, tells you already the kind
of populism associated with it. It's like enough, enough
of the enough. Of the current,
I thought it was a bit ruder. I thought
it was a bit more like go away, you
know,
I mean the direct translation is enough, but I
mean maybe someone could translate it that way. I'm
not sure, but the direct translation is enough.
And so, very good, yeah.
Yeah, OK, so in the book you also talk
or explore postwar democratic theory. So earlier you talked
a little bit about the work of Gaetanomosa, Wilfredo
Pareto, Robert Mikkelsen. Could you tell us now a
little bit about how the work of people like
Joseph Cumpeter, Robert Dolan, C. Wright Mills, and Raymond
Aaron helps us understand post-war democratic theory.
Yeah, thanks. That's a relatively large subject, but part
of what I do in the book, as you
rightly say, in the, in the first half, in
some ways, I try to recover the thinking of
Mosca Preto. Um, AND Niels, as a way of
saying, there's a tendency to kind of lump the
three together as being the same thing. But if
we separate them out, they have different emphasis, different
political alignments, different contexts, you know, Italy, Germany, um,
Switzerland even. And also, I think, um, when we
do that, you see the theories are, have their
own emphasis, history, sociology, whatever it might be, um,
bureaucratization. And it's, so it's, it's a richer picture
than we can draw upon. So what, what I
try to do then is I try to say
in the second half of the book is to
say, OK, the, the very kind of representative figures
of social sciences and democratic theory post, uh, post-war,
admittedly this is a kind of a, uh, an
American, German, French, and um I'm conscious of in
the future work, I want to do a more
Europe, a kind of slightly more European story. I'd
like to have more Portugal, Spain, and, and obviously
Italy's in it too. Um, MAYBE some of the
Scandinavian countries, but, um, it's to say, some of
these emblematic figures, as you've mentioned, Joseph Schumpeter, Robert
Daw, Sierra Bales is quite American, Raymond A in
France, um, that we can't understand the development of
their theories and their ideas without seeing how they
were in dialogue with the first three, that I
mentioned before. And if we see that, then it
actually sheds also a different light on their theories
than the way that we normally think about it.
And so, I think Joseph Schumpeter, we've, we mentioned
him already, where he says, you know, the conventional
view of democracy is people come together, and then
which through their general will, they elect representatives to
execute that general, and he says, you know, that's,
that's just not realistic. And in fact, one of
the people he explicitly cites as saying that that's
not realistic because politics is a lot more irrational
than it is rational, is explicitly Peretto. He says
Perreto has taught us this. And he instead proposes
this, this view that's been called either elite competition
or minimalist democracy, although neither of those terms are
terms he uses himself. He talks about more rule
by politicians or leadership democracy, which is instead you
have, you know, elites who come about, and then
they, they come up suggesting that they try to
capture the market for votes. It's a very, again,
economic perspective. Um, AND so, uh, I, I try
to show, uh, so that's obviously linked explicitly to,
to the early elites, but I just try to
show how, what, what Schpeter has done is that
he's really reduced the type of competition simply to
a small political sphere among political elites. Whereas, as
I was talking earlier on, just even in terms
of Pareto, the circulation is not just politics, it's
like economics and society has a broader, um, a
broader aspect to it, and you could say the
same for Moscow and Mikkels. And so, I think
that Trumpmpeter maybe has, in, in, in focusing on
elections in particular, he's, he's really pinpointed a certain
important thing within, within democracy, and he, and he
defends that, and as a normative defense, that's fine.
But if we want analytical tools to try to
understand what we are today, I think the other
three have a richer canvas, or a richer background
upon which we can draw. So I just want
to point out for them. Moving quickly on then,
if you want, C. Wright Mills or Robert Dow,
um, in the US in particular, there's a, there's
in, um, both of them in 1956 published a
book, very interestingly. So C. Wright Mills published a
book called The Power Elite, which is basically the
military-industrial complex, that's basically what he's arguing, in 1956.
And the same year, Robert Dall publishes a book
called A Preface to Democratic Theory. Which is the
beginning of his reflections on democratic theory, and ultimately
will lead to his, to his notion of polyarchy
as being a form of a modern democracy. So,
it's not ideal, but it's a kind of a
second order. That debate, by the way, C. Wright
Mills, the power elite, you talk about in also
in Portuguese, that it doesn't have the accent. I
think it's with C. Wright Mills in 1956, the
Our elite, as he calls the book, doesn't have
the accent. It becomes anglicized or loses the accent.
Also, I think it's a moment where the term
becomes perhaps a bit more pejorative, that with Peretto,
it was both an analytical tool, but also, as
we discussed previously, he was trying to say, you
know, we, we should have the best, right? We
should have the best rule. Here with CY Mills,
it becomes pejorative, you know, it's, it's the military-industrial
complex, so it's linked to the presidents, so it's
pejorative. But normally that debate between the two is
is constructed as or presented as being, oh, this
is the C. Wright Mills is the kind of
elite thinker, and Robert Dahl is the defender of
democracy. And what I want to say is like
actually you've seen from the, the broader historical canvas.
There are two sides of the same elite coin,
because they both agreed that they're elites in the
system. The question is whether elites are more likely
to to cooperate. If they cooperate, then we get
the power elite. If they compete, then we get
polyarchy. So they're both elite thinkers, or they both
accept elites. It's just that they give you a
sense of um if they compete or they cooperate,
you get different forms of politics. Finally, then you
have um Remoon, who again during the Cold War
was trying to think about what's the difference between
Western democracy and Eastern democracy in the European context,
because, you know, let's not forget that obviously the
East were saying, no, no, you know, we're the
true proletarian democracy. We're, we're not this bourgeois liberal
democracy, we're the true one. And obviously on the
Western, no, no, we're the true democracy, you guys
are a dictatorship, right? And so he was trying
to develop a a a a way to, to
analyze that, and he does start explicitly with what
he says, the fact of oligarchy. He says, OK,
there is, there are elites in both systems. And
the question again is whether elites are more likely
to be divided, so that there's a separation and
different political institutions that separate out the political, economic,
social, judiciary, etc. ELITES that they have their own
space, or whether that all these elites, political, social,
economic, are all in the same institution, namely the
Communist Party. So that's his way of distinguishing, so
they're divided or united. Um, AND then from that
point on, he's able to, to pass a kind
of a judgment, both, both negative and positive. He
says, well, if you are, um, if you are
pursued by in terms of, in terms of how
much there's a bit more defense for the people
more generally, in the context of Eastern democracy, if
you want, you know, if, if the elite, if
the Communist Party comes after you for whatever reason,
You kind of have nowhere to turn. There's, there's
no one, you've nothing to defend yourself. Whereas in
the Western one, at least, he says, OK, well,
if one of the elites comes after you, then
maybe you can turn to another elite for defense,
and you could play them one after the other.
So that's a kind of a negative defense. But
to go back to Machiavelli, who, whom we kind
of started with the prince, but instead of the
prince, think about the discourses, right? The discourses of
Livy on the Roman Republic. Where Machiavelli says, you
know, the reason why the Roman Republic was free
was because there was this tumult, this competition or
this conflict between the plebs and the patricians, between
the elites and the masses, if you want. And,
um, Aron takes that and takes a kind of
a more liberal interpretation, and says, OK, actually, if
you put that in the context of the divided
elites, the fact that the elites are divided and
that there's competition or conflict between them, means that
there's a possibility of liberty to emerge from that
system. Therefore, that's why that system is potentially better.
So that's what I tried to, sorry, that was
quite long, I realized, but I was trying to
reconstruct and show how it, it, it, it makes
us see things differently, but then also have certain
normative, normative and analytical consequences that comes out of
it.
So I would like to further explore one of
the aspects that you mentioned in your answer there.
So what role has post-war democratic theory played in
the development of the social sciences? I mean, I'm,
I'm very interested in hearing more about that and,
and also. So why do you think it's important
for people to have an understanding or a or
a better understanding as to the potential role or
the link there that there was between democratic theory
post-war and the development of the social sciences?
Yeah, so, and actually, um, maybe I went over
this a bit um too quickly, but all the,
all these figures don't just show Schumpeter, Cra M,
Robertau. Um, I, I've focused so far in my
responses on the kind of the contribution to democratic
theory, but they have much broader, um, um, contributions
in general. Schumpeter is obviously again, best known as
an economist. C. Wright Mills probably more as, as
a, as a sociologist, Robert Dahl as a, yes,
political theorist, but political scientist. Involved in the behavioral
kind of revolution and Remoiron wrote, is probably still
better known as a kind of theories of international
relations when he was talking to um Kissing close
to Kissinger or Kissinger at least, thought he was
um somebody worthwhile listening to, and Mossa's theories of
history and sociology and relationship to Weber. So there's
a broader picture there to start off with. Um.
And, um, there are methodological, um, um, kind of
debates that are going there. But, what I'm trying
to do in, in short, the short answer to
your question is to say, um, within all these
developments, I think we've slightly, um, lost from sight
the fact that all of them have elites as
a key part of their theories, whether it's economics,
sociology, whatever it might be. And, um, And I
think today, today we've lost slightly sight of that.
At the time, it was clear, because they were
explicitly saying, oh, we're, you know, we're engaging with
Pareto's idea, you know, C. Wright Mills uses the
word elite, right? You know, where is he taking
it from? So, at the time, so in post-war,
we could still see it. I think now we've
lost it. So we just take these theories as
if they were, they were just empirically pure theories,
if you want. Whereas actually, they have a certain
basis, at least analytical basis. WHICH is the existence
of elites in the political system. And I just,
I want to bring that back to light because
I think one of the things we've, we've slightly
lost from view in the social sciences and democratic
theory today is precisely that there are elites within
political systems. We tend to focus simply on democracy
understood as perhaps social movements, participation, all these types
of things, both in, um, both in democratic theory
and the social sciences. But actually, we need to
theorize, um, clearly also the existence of elites, and
what I try to advocate for in the book
is to think about politics as a relationship between
the two. That's what we need to think about.
Um, SO that's on one hand. There, there's the
other hand also too where some of the social
sciences has, the accusation is, is that perhaps it's
a bit, in, especially in America, perhaps a bit
conservative, where it was worried about the masses, um,
And wanted to stabilize the political system and was
worried about too much participation. This is sometimes a
criticism that's been leveled at somebody like Robert Dahl
at certain moments of his life. Sometimes, there were
other moments earlier or later where he was a
bit more radical, was interested in economic democracy, perhaps.
But during the Cold War period, there is a
broader sense in political science that there's concern about
stabilizing the political system and not being overwhelmed. Um,
BUT again, you can only see that, I think,
from the fact that they're engaging with these elite
theorists sometimes then to, to affirm it and then
to preserve the political system. Um, OTHER times not.
Um, BUT it's again on whichever side it goes,
is to bring back the centrality of thinking about
elites within the social sciences of democratic theory more
generally, which I think, um, today has been slightly
overlooked.
So when people talk about the possibility of social
transformation, what do you think is possible within this
framework of looking at society as a relationship between
elites and democracy? Uh, I mean, because for example,
if you take it to an extreme and you
are an an anarchist and you think that probably.
Probably the best version of society, the best way
of society existing would be uh non-hierarchical, I mean
stateless, do away with the elites. Let's just let
the people organize themselves non-hierarchically, and I mean, do
you think, of course I'm not completely sure if
this is um. If this is a fair question
to ask you because we would probably need also
an anthropologist here, but do you think that at
least in large scale complex societies, the one, the
ones that most living people live in today, That
it's really possible to do away with the elites,
for example. I, I mean, to what extent do
you think it's possible to transform society?
So in large scale complex societies, can we get
away with elites? The answer to that, I think
is no. I don't think we can. Um, IT'S
not to say now, all three of the thinkers
though, did think that, um, so, some of them
like Moscow thought, you know, in, in, in slightly,
in some earlier primitive societies, then you didn't have
the same distinction between ruler and rule. It's only
over when you get to a certain Um, size.
And in fact, some political scientists looking more at
political parties have suggested, oh, if there's only like
about 1000 members who are there, then, then you
can keep a kind of a semblance of equality
and, and, and, and, and, and democratic equality and
participation. But once it gets over a certain size,
and it just becomes impossible because you need to
organize in such a way. And once you say
organization, this is his famous line by Robert Mills,
who says organization says oligarchy, that organization by its
very nature is going to lead to a class
of organizers, officials, or whatever, who are going to
organize the day to day meeting and responses, etc.
ETC. And that will just, they will be slightly
sad. Separate from the members at a whole and
will retain more power than they do. So in
large scale societies, I, um, and these thinkers, I
just don't think that's possible. I, um, and, um,
so there's a few things to say from that.
You ask also is social transformation possible. I think
it is very much possible. Um, IT'S just,
but what, what are the limits within this framework.
THAT you present in your book.
Yes, so the limits are that regardless of which
type of political regime we're going to come up
with, there's still going to be elites who rule
that. So there is a hard, so elites are
not, um, they are a feature of the system,
they're a bug. I don't think you can get
away with it, but it doesn't mean you can't
get very, very different systems. Obviously, if you go
back to the Cold War, you know, the Eastern
Bloc and the Western bloc were quite different types
of political regimes. The simple claim there, at least,
is to say, but You know, and, and all
three thinkers, Perreto, Mikhaels, and Moscow were very much
engaging with Marxism and found it very interesting. And
they often thought, yes, they're right about conflict as
being as the key of politics. They just simply
did not believe that should there be a proletarian
revolution, that conflict and the state. And um class
would disappear. They just thought a new elite would
rise up. Um, AND they were very interested in
knowing which elite that would be, which is why,
um, when I said Perreto coined the term elite
in 2002, the name of the book he's, with
which this occurs is called The System Socialist, The
Socialist Systems, because he's actually analyzing the rising class
of, of socialists, and, and their social leader, and
he wants to know which type of rulers they're
going to be. And he actually thinks that they're
going to be lions. Because it's a faith-based politics.
Marxism is a form of secular religion, and therefore
there will be lions when they come to power,
at least according to, um, to Pareto. Um, SO
that's the constraints. So you can, you know, if
you take Perreto, you can have the lions and
the foxes in power, and they will look very,
very different over, depending on which historical moment we're
we're talking about. But the constraints is um, So,
there are constraints, which is simply that there will
always be um elites. But I think some people,
you know, some people say, oh, once you say
elites, that means like, you know, you kind of
give up and nothing is possible. I say, no,
no, no. Actually, once you say that there are
elites, then you can have lots of other interesting
conversations. Firstly, you might be able to say, OK,
we know there's, we know exactly where the challenge
lies. Which is that there's always going to be
elites, but we can challenge those elites, we can
change them. We can also ask other types of
questions like which type of elites do we have,
um, what type of elites do we want them
to be, which type of formation do they go
through? Obviously, like, you know, the elites that you
have in the UK, we often talk about Oxford's
PPE, Oxford philosophy, Politics and Economics being The degree
that runs Britain, you know, that's a certain type
of formation, and that's very different to the type
of formation, for instance, you get in France with
Champsbo and Lennard, which are much more kind of
civil service type of elite. So already that's very
different, and, and I think this, all these, um,
theories allow us to have these conversations which we
wouldn't have. And I think they're also they're serious
conversations. I realize people will say, well, we do,
you know, we want to completely change everything, etc.
ETC. AND have perhaps a bit more a revolutionary
impulse, which I understand. Here, I, I, I, I
suppose I would accept the fact that people say
this is a bit more reformist. It's more reformist
than it is revolutionary. I think that's true. Um,
AND it's also because I think that, um, that
sometimes we get more results out of reform than
we do with revolution. I'm not saying it's easy
to get in, in other ways. There are dangers
with, with revolution, there are dangers with reform, but
here it's saying, OK, we can get real, real
change, and some of it could be very, very
positive. Um, Miels, when he's studying the, the German
Social Democratic Party, which at the time is the
richest, the most powerful, um, social, socialist party in
the world, and it's on the cusp of coming
to power. He accuses the leaders of not being
sufficiently revolutionary. Which is fair. But then if you
look at the, the, the increase in living standards
of the workers, it goes through the roof, right?
You know, the, the, uh, their days are, their
working days are reduced, they have more social protection,
you know, and in the end, um, you know,
Bismarck gives them a social welfare. So, um, which
one would you rather have? Um, AND I think
I'm more, I think at least I want to
defend the possibility that, that having social welfare, if
you take that as one of the consequences of
what happens here, is something worthwhile, um, worth having
too.
Yeah, and I think that also, I mean, it's
very unrealistic to think that we can do away
with elites in a large scale complex societies, starting
with the fact that because we have specialized activities,
I mean, we have to be able to coordinate
all of them across society. Yeah, I mean, and
I mean the, the only way, at least that
I can think of to do that and the
only way that I think every society on that
scale that has ever existed, came up with was
to have a form of centralized political power. And
I mean, once you have centralized political power. And
you have certain people taking over certain institutions in
society. I, I, I mean, it's virtually impossible for
you to not have elites in some way, right?
I mean, I, I don't, I don't think it's
possible any other way. So
yes, I agree, I agree. So there's a kind
of a realistic comment about where we are today,
but also a kind of a positive one, which
is that You know, um, sometimes these elites or
experts or whatever you want to call them, it's,
it's positive too. Um, YOU might say, you know,
can we, if we didn't have the state today,
even though it's under a lot of pressure. Um,
YOU know, would we be able to still have
a degree of social welfare in these things that
we don't have? Obviously, the answer to that is
to say, well, you know, we should, if we
never had the state, we didn't have capitalism, then
we wouldn't have all these things to start off
with, which is a fair point. Um, BUT given
where we are, um, now, then, um, there are
certain positive things, um, that come out of it,
that come out of the existence of elites, that
come out of the centralized state. That we should
be aware of. Um, AND if we, if we
want to get rid of it completely, we should
be aware of all the things that we would
probably get rid of with that too. So, um,
so it's just, it's, it's, I don't deny at
all. I, I, I, I don't want to come
across as somebody who's denying the, the anarchist or,
or, or the revolution pushes and doesn't have, doesn't
make good points. Um, I, um, I do want
to say that, OK, but if you want to
do this, here are the other things you need
to take into consideration, and I, In general, yes,
it's true. I think that these are perhaps more
worthwhile than, you know, it's more worthwhile. I'm not
saying absolutely, but more worthwhile. Um, AND given where
we are today, maybe this is something more realistic,
um, to try to achieve.
So I have one last topic that I would
like to explore with you today. How do you
look at our current political predicament? I mean by
that, I mean, for example, if you look at
the US, if you look at the UK, if
you look at several other European countries, even Japan
to a certain extent, a certain degree of political,
economic, and social instability, a certain sense that people
have that the future is to a certain degree
hopeless because they look around them and they see,
for example, rising levels. Of economic inequality, uh, I
mean, people, many people, uh, see it, see that
it's harder and harder for them to afford even
the basics of life. Uh, WE have climate change,
of course, and other political issues, even wars and
stuff like that, that we can also include into
the picture. Um, HOW do you look at our
predicament and, uh, I mean, taking into account the
framework as to the interplay between elites and democracy
that you present in your book, in what ways
do you think we could act upon it?
Yeah, so I think a few things there, and
it also depends slightly on which context we're talking
about. I have in mind the fact that um
Samuel Moyne, um, I think a kind of a
public intellectual figure in the US has just brought
out this book, um, accusing the US as being
a form of gerontocracy, right? It's the old people
who've kind of controlled everything. I think That might
have been slightly more valid in the political sphere
when there was Trump versus Biden. Obviously, Kamala Harris
changed things, but he, he has a more structural
point he wants to make. But that reminds me
of precisely the type of um worries that people
like Peretto in Moscow had, this idea of crystallization,
right? Is that there's a certain generation of hoarded
stuff, and precisely, there's not enough circulation. That's, that's
what you say, like, people don't feel they can
afford to buy a house, they can, they can
move in, in the ways that they would have
wanted, um, that they feel stuck, that they feel
static. Again, that's one of the contrasts, I, uh,
contrast I try to make, um, in the book
between a kind of a dynamic view of democracy
of democracy or society more generally one on, on
circulation, and a more static one, which is, um,
which is more a bit stuck. And I think
people feel that's, that's staticism at the moment, that
they would like more circulation. So I think, I'd
like to think it's still very, um, very relevant.
You might say in the UK there's a bit
too much instability, um, right, there's a lot of
prime ministers that are going through, and somebody like
Aron. He was very clear on this too. He
said, OK, I, you know, yes, I, I agree
generally with divided elites, but that can go too
far and you lose the, the possibility of, of,
of, um, of efficiency too. So, these are always
things within a broader scale, but in general, they're
more on the side of circulation, precisely because, um,
you know, when the disruption of politics, if you
want change. So there's a couple of things to
say there. One is that You know, if you're
despairing at the situation you find yourself in today,
politically, economic, and socially, this theory reminds you that
there is always change, that there is always change
coming. There's never a full stop. Sometimes that change
is slower, sometimes that changes faster, and in general,
the theory advocates for having it slightly faster, but
the change always comes about. So, hold, hold, hold
on for a bit and hopefully things will change.
Um, AND secondly, is that precisely, it's, it's precisely
when these moments have changed that things, that, that,
that there's a possibility, there's a possibility of change,
but it's in the circulation and in the challenge
that there's a possibility of change. Some of them
might be good, some of them, some of them
might be bad. That's hard to tell, um, a
priori, why we don't, there's a challenge, like we
don't exactly know, that's, that's the indeterminacy of politics
more generally democracy in particular. Yet hopefully the demo,
the dynamic democracy gives you this framework to be
able to say, OK. You know, is this challenge
going to be pushed towards democracy, um, or not?
And, and to that, if I may, um, the,
the, the book also tries to identify precisely where
this, where a change may happen in a more
profound sense than simply left or right or changing
prime ministers or whatever it might be, because in
the UK I think, you know, there's been this
radical Brexit change. And, and society is still trying
to, still trying to figure it out. And one
way of figuring it out is to go through
the circulation, actually. Um, SO, this is, this is
what it's, it's part of, and we'll see, it
sounds like Andy Burnham is now going to become
the new prime minister. We'll see what he's able
to do or not, whether he's able to stabilize
it or not. Um, BUT in a book drawing
a kind of some, from social theory, I, I
say that if you want to see a kind
of a slightly more profound change, if, if, if
you use the, The Peret in terms of lions
and foxes, as opposed to simply saying left and
right. Um Then the three elements to look for
are, one, you need something like a, a social
movement or a social protest, you need something that's
putting pressure on the political system. Um, BUT what
you, uh, what you also need is you, you,
you still have elites, but you need a section
of the elite, the established elite to, to break
off and join that social movement to challenge the
established elite. And normally that, That kind of mediation
and that coming together is done through, historically in,
in, in modernity has been political parties, that's the
role they've played, to go back to your first
question. Political parties. Now, today, but it doesn't have
to be political parties. It could be different types
of political institutions, and there's a lot of thinking
today about whether one of the ways of trying
to revive democracy is to have, you know, autocracies
like selection by, by lot as opposed to elections,
etc. But these are all different forms of political
institution, and what I say to all those people
is like, you know, that's very interesting and maybe
yes, it will revive democracy, and that's welcome. But
don't think it's going to get rid of elites.
It's just going to bring a new elite. There's
a sortian elite that's gonna, that's gonna come about.
We could talk about certain specifics. I'm, I'm half
Irish. Ireland has had a lot of these different
experiments, and they've been quite interesting and being perhaps
politically successful, um, but, um, it would be, it
would be a bit naive to think it's just
people came together and made these decisions. No, no,
it was. It was already the parliament who decided
it. Half of the people involved were politicians. The
other were drawn from the population at large. It
lasted for a few years, I think 2 years
at least, and they brought in all these different
experts to discuss with them on lots of different
legal, technical points, etc. ETC. So, that looks, but
that looks to me like dynamic democracy, because it's
precisely about bringing elites, you know, and the people
together, having a discussion, trying to work it out.
And then it was put to referendum to the
people at large. So, those are very interesting models,
but I'm simply saying, don't think they're going to
get rid of elites altogether and that all of
a sudden we're going to achieve democracy. That's the
one thing I would say. Um. Perhaps the final
thing, if, if, if, if I may, I mean
this is the image that I try to use
in the book to try to capture this idea
of dynamic democracy. Mikkels uses this at the end
of his book on political parties. He, he brings
back to life, um, Aesop's fables, so, um, ancient,
um, the ancients, um, who, who has this fable
of the dying peasant on his deathbed who tells
his children, there's a buried treasure in the field.
Um, AND so the peasant dies, and I presume,
or I hope at least the children are sad
for a bit, but then they're very excited and
they go out to the field because there's a
buried treasure, and they want to find the buried
treasure, and they dig, they dig, they dig all
the fields, they go around, they dig, dig, dig,
dig, dig, dig, dig, and of course, They never
find a treasure, but in having tilled the land,
they've made the land richer, and they've made themselves
richer. And that's kind of, um, I think that's
the metaphor I'm I'm trying to hold on with
this idea of dynamic democracy. True democracy, to go
back to your very first question, you know, sovereignty
of the people, majority, we're never going to achieve
that fully because Iliso is rule, right? We're never
going to achieve it. Nevertheless, It's worth striving towards
it, because we might get lots of democratic benefits
that might come from it. And, and again, if
you more in the historical case, we've've spoken about
the German Social Democratic Party. Yeah, sure, they never
achieved perhaps socialist revolution in the way their ideology
was meant to do so, but the plight of
the workers got so much better than it was
before. Um, SO that, and I'm trying to say,
well, maybe that's something that's, that's worthwhile keeping in
mind, and we can give perhaps contemporary examples of
that too.
Yes, and that last example that you gave there,
I think that's one of the reasons why it's
important to not just simply dismiss political movements that
are looked at as more radical. I mean, even
on the left, for example, communists, socialists, and all
of that, because Even if for several different reasons
it's not possible to really transform society in the
way that they intend, they can still have a
positive impact and improve society in different ways in
that striving toward that ideal.
That, yes, that's exactly what I'm trying to say,
and obviously, what I've given you is an example
of a direct political um impact of needing those
three elements. There may be huge societal economic impacts,
um, too, but I just want to say analytically,
it seems to be the case that a social
movement on its On its own will not um
generate a stronger structural change. It needs a part
of um the elite to come over to its
size. Um, AND, and, you know, you can give
it the US again, perhaps a more neutral example
for us, but the US as an example for
this because, um, and maybe, you know, this is
a negative example, I think for us, but in
terms of, uh, but just to show that this
is applicable on both sides, I don't think in
2016. Um, THE primaries when Trump is, is challenging,
it's quite interesting because already he's bringing a lot
of people in who said that they didn't consider
themselves to be Republicans. So he's bringing new people
into politics. But would Trump have ever really gotten
to where he was if a section of the
Republican Party itself didn't decide to go over to
its side, like Speaker Paul Ryan, Senator Mitch McConnell,
these people say, OK, you know what, we're gonna,
we're gonna, we'll give, we'll give up on Jeb
Bush or the more established Republicans, and we'll go
over here because we think we can win with
this guy. So there's a section of the established
elite that joins, and it's run through obviously the
political party, the primaries of the Republican Party. There's
an example. Of how it comes about. Perhaps a
negative example. If you want, I don't know if
there's maybe a more positive or a more hopeful
or maybe a more European example also, if you
think about what just happened in Hungary, um, not
long ago, right, with, um, with, um, with Magyar,
who is a member of the established elite, right?
He's a, he's a member of Fidesz of Orban's
party, but at the moment decides he's had enough,
he breaks from it. He joins the protest movement.
THAT are there against the corruption and the covering
up of the Orban regime, runs it through a
political party. He, he didn't, it already existed, um,
but he, he kind of seizes upon it, and
then he's able to overthrow, overthrow the Orban regime
in many ways, right? To a lot of people's
surprise, like people thought he might do it, but
it was quite, it was much more convincing than
anybody expected it to be. Um, THERE'S a, there's
another version of that, perhaps a more positive one.
And one of the, the more interesting things I
think he said, um, in terms of the reforms
he was going to advocate going forward, was this
idea to have limited terms for the prime minister,
uh, right, which is a form of dynamism. It's
OK, like you can only have two terms, so
we're going to make sure that keeps a certain
velocity, whereas Orban had say for 16 years in
a row or something like that, right? So, OK,
that's not going to be possible. We're going to
have this surrogate so institutionally. You know, bringing in
this kind of dynamism into it. And I think
that was, that was quite interesting. Who, I don't,
I, it's hard to predict what's going to happen
in the future, but that was a moment, I
think, in which this theory was, um, was cashed
out in a way.
Mhm. OK, great. So, uh, the book is again
Elites and Democracy, and I'm of course leaving a
link to it in the description of the interview.
And Dr. Hoon, apart from the book, would you
like to let people know where they can find
you and your work on the internet?
Yeah, that's very kind. I do, um, I still
have, I still have an ex, I think, account
where I, I used to, I tweet, I suppose.
I know, I still tweet. There's Facebook, and then
I have, obviously the, the, the web, the web
page at the University of Nottingham. But yeah, Twitter,
I suppose, is where I try to, I'm not
the best, but I try to, try to keep
it going.
OK, great. So, thank you so much for taking
the time to come on the show. It's been
a fascinating conversation.
Thanks so much, Ricardo. Great questions. Also, this is
what's great about talking these things because it allows
you to, to think through even the, the things
I wrote in the book. It's like, oh, but
here's another way of explaining that, which, which is
great and clarifying it. So this is, this was
very helpful for me too. So, and hopefully, obviously
your viewers and listeners will get something from it
too.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoro, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolatti, Gabriel Pan Scortez
or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Ebert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.